there's an old joke you know how many
how many psychiatrist does it take to
change a lightbulb one but the lightbulb
has to really want to change you'll get
it later the number one my friend George
Flinn who's a three-star retired general
in the Marine Corps he says it best
he says the the most important criterion
if you want to be a leader is you have
to want to be one right if you any
Marines in the audience know so if you
enlist in the Marine Corps and you go to
Parris Island or San Diego if you go to
boot camp I don't care how much you hate
it you can't drop out of the Marine
Corps like you signed a contract you're
in for whatever you're you're three four
years is that's it too bad haha right if
you go to OCS if you go to Officer
Candidate School because you want to be
an officer in the Marine Corps one of
the leaders in the Marine Corps out of
the 10-week program you have to do the
first four weeks but then for the next
six weeks at any point at any time for
any reason if you want to drop out you
can and the reason is because the Marine
Corps only wants people in leadership
positions who want to be leaders if you
don't want to be a leader they don't
want you right it's the same here if
you're a finite player and you want to
be an infinite player that's like saying
I want to get into shape it's a
completely new lifestyle you're gonna
have to live you can have to give it
bread you're gonna have to give up sugar
you have to go to the gym on a regular
basis which by the way just like this
journey there's no daily indicator you
can't go to the gym and then come home
and look in the mirror you'll see
nothing you'll go to the next day
because your friends say this gym thing
is like all the rage and you'll come
back and you'll look in the mirror and
you'll see nothing and you'll be in pain
and so you'll quit because you don't see
any short-term results the same is true
for the journey I'm talking about you
will not see anything on a daily basis
you will not see it and you might
actually suffer short-term liability you
actually might see the short-term
numbers go down or stress go up it's
because you're changing the way you
approach your problems you're changing
the way you approach your business and
there's gonna be some bumpiness
but like the gym if
stick with it it gets easier and you
start to see results the other problem
is we all get in shape at different
times so when you say how long does it
take to become an infinite an infinite
minded leader the answer is I don't know
how long does it take to get into shape
I don't know if you've been doing it for
like five years and you see no results
you're doing something wrong it's a
lifestyle you're opting for an entirely
new lifestyle an entirely new way of
viewing the world an entirely new way of
seeing the way business works and you're
a role within it and so the choice the
choice the choice to become an infinite
minded businessperson is your choice it
starts with your desire because it is
really hard everything that I have told
you today is unbelievably hard it is
much easier to be finite minded you get
positive reinforcement on a daily basis
you can turn one knob and you can see
the numbers go up or down I'm asking if
you want to opt for an entirely new
lifestyle one that turns out it happens
to be a lot healthier
[Music]
[Music]